let's see if we can divide 30.2 for
divide it by 0.42 and try pausing the
video and and solving it on your own
before I work through it so there's a
couple of ways you could think about it
we could just write it as 30 0.2 4 / /
0.42 0.42 but what do you do now well
the important realization is is when
you're doing a division problem like
this if you will get the same answer as
long as you multiply or divide both
numbers by the same thing and to
understand that we could rewrite that at
rewrite this division as 30 0.42 / /
0.42 we could write it really as a
fraction and we know that when we have a
fraction like this we're not changing
the value of the fraction if we multiply
the numerator and the denominator by the
same quantity and so what could we
multiply this denominator by to make it
a whole number well we can multiply it
by 10 and then another 10 so we could
multiply it by a hundred so let's do
that if we multiply the denominator by
100 in order to not change the value of
this we also need to multiply the
numerator by 100 we're essentially
multiplying by 100 over 100 which is
just 1 so we're not changing the value
of this fraction or you could view this
of this this division problem so this is
going to be 30 point 4 2 times 100 move
the decimal 2 places to the right
gets you 3040 - the decimal is now there
if you care about it and 0.42 x 100 once
again move the decimal one two places to
the right
it is now 42 so this is going to be the
exact same thing as three thousand
forty-two divided by 42 so once again we
can move the decimal here two to the
right and if we move that two to the
right then we can move this two to the
right or we need to move this two to the
right and so this is where now the
decimal places you could view this as
3024 we clear that 3000 and 24/40 - let
me clear that and we know how to tackle
that already but let's do it step by
step how many times does 42 go into
three well it doesn't go at all so we
can move on to 30 how many times does 42
go into 30 well it doesn't go into 30 so
we can move on to 302 how many times
does 42 go into 302 and like always this
is a bit of an art when you're dividing
by a two-digit or a multi digit number I
should say so let's think about it a
little bit so this is roughly 40 this is
roughly 300 so how many times is 40
going to 300 well how many times does 4
go into 30 it looks likes about 7 times
so I'm going to try out a 7 see if it
works out 7 times 2 is 14 7 times 4 is
28 plus 1 is 29 and now I can subtract
to do a little bit of regrouping here so
let's see if I regroup I take a hundred
from the 300 that becomes a 200 then our
zero tens now I have 10 tens but I'm
going to need one of those 10 tens so
that's going to be nine tens and I'm
going to give it over here and so this
is going to be a 12 12 minus 4 12 minus
4 is 8 9 minus 9 is 0 2 minus 2 is 0 so
what I got left over is less than 42 so
I know that 7 is the right number I want
to go as many times as possible into 302
without going over so now let's bring
down now let's bring down the next digit
let's bring down this 4 over here how
many times does 42 go into 84 well that
jumps out at you or hopefully a jump or
it starts to that 4 it goes 2 times 2
times 2 is 4 2 times 2 times 4 is 8
you subtract and we have no remainder so
3042 divided by 42 is the same thing as
30 point 4 2 divided by 0.42 and it's
going to be equal to 72
it's going to be equal to 72 actually
I'd have to copy and paste that I'll
just write this this is equal to 72 this
is equal to 72 72 just like that